how adorable is that
Snooki's been spending her time in
quarantine getting tic toc lessons from
her five-year-old daughter so he's
teaching him how to tick tock well she's
got me teaching me because I just feel
like I'm too old
she's been teaching me all the moves and
everything so I love the fact that my
tick tock is all about my kids
Snookie has been showing off her
adorable corn team on social media in
addition to Giovanna she has seven year
old son Lorenzo and their baby meatball
Angelo who's about to turn one and of
course her husband to five years Gianni
it's starting to get exhausting because
I have three kids here so the schooling
isn't great because they listen to a
teacher they like respect the teacher my
kids are like I'm not doing that
they just don't respect me as a teacher
Mowrey managing and navigating it with
your husband I mean some days are
amazing some days I'm like can you just
leave me alone
I'm like you're breathing too loud
you're too loud please go away
of course you can see Snooki with her
other family tonight on MTV's Jersey
Shore family vacation this is her last
season with the group Snooki recently
announced she quit the franchise I never
want to do that again I just don't want
the drama filming anymore
I can't do it so I decided to leave my
roomies know that I still love them and
I will root for them and you know I just
need to do something different
[Music]